he had reached
such a different pinnacle in l.a
with all gangs that dudes from every set
want to come pay respect
you know i mean and we wanted to
you wanted to facilitate that you know
what i mean and it was so beautiful man
and i'm so glad that i was just a part
of it
and i was able to to make that happen
because that was great for l.a man that
was great
for our souls you know what i mean right
all right to see some dudes we had been
fighting with for years
yeah because like like you know like
is it almost take an event like that to
happen
not i'm not specifically talking about
nip's death but something of that
magnitude
to happen to kind of because you know
it's it's hard to tell someone to stop
going to war with somebody if their
uncle died or their
brother died because it was a lot of
backlash
on our side it was backlash on our side
other gang
size you know because dudes who still
like you said would feel a certain way
so
it was it was a call that was made and
people came and they still had to go
back and like man with these dudes or
enemies still
so you know and with understanding that
that people
lost fathers uncles cousins yeah you
know you got to respect that but
that day showed that we could find a way
out
and that was our mission when we first
started with this you got to take you
back to that
and the reason why a lot of gangs
respected him is because we made sure i
made sure we didn't ditch nobody
in the beginning of his music i went
through all the videos watched all the
video watch all the signs in the world
no blob that out no signs this anymore i
made sure my homies didn't put up
nothing disrespecting nobody
if you look at them videos that was all
me mm-hmm you know what i'm saying
and then of course nip grew into that of
course because his first music was
rolling sixties brothers and girls you
know and we cleaned all that up
you know what i mean and that was it
yeah
his history you know it's all history
now man